es masiva la participación en esta
edición número 31 de la marcha del
orgullo en la ciudad de Buenos Aires es
un festejo una celebración Pero también
es una oportunidad para pedir mayores
derechos para los colectivos que
participan del evento por eso los
organizadores hablan este año en su
eslogan de la deuda es con nosotros eso
es una referencia la deuda externa
Argentina pero también a la deuda de
derechos para los colectivos que
participan especialmente para las
personas trans por eso se está pidiendo
en esta marcha por una ley integral
trans también por una ley
antidiscriminación y también se está
marchando en defensa del lenguaje
inclusivo